my name is Jessamine West and I'm a
community moderator at metafilter com I
travel around the country doing sort of
public speaking kind of stuff about what
I do in my tiny town because there's not
a lot of people who both work with small
rural libraries and as well have a
technical background and as well can
travel to tell other people about it so
I speak nationally and internationally
about those things how you can use to
point o technology to help bridge the
digital divide how you know people who
are just getting online in 2008 how
that's different for them and when we
got online in you know 1988 something
like that I grew up in a small town move
to Seattle you know and was there in the
90s which was what a lot of people my
age were doing and I had a job at the
time working for an Internet service
provider at around the time I bought a
place in Vermont so for about two years
i was actually bicoastal schlepping my
stuff across the country and I did tech
support / email so I could set up in my
little house in Central Vermont with my
then dial up connection but you know
using instant messenger and being able
to use technology sort of on my computer
in order to stay in touch with the
office in Seattle and that was great
like it enabled me to spend half the
year in Vermont fixing my barn and then
the other half in Seattle interacting
actually in person with folks and then I
guess six years ago I moved full-time to
Vermont basically the combination of a
laptop that I can connect to the
internet however that works and it
doesn't just mean dialing up from home
it can mean at the internet cafe it can
mean at the airport it can mean with my
wireless card it can mean using my
handheld sort of PDA to connect to
wireless having my cell phone and having
people text me and web tools are now
advanced to the point where they're
expecting that and so there's been this
convergence of more freely available
sort of internet in the air combined
with
receivers that catch that and enable you
to actually interact with your world
your people your job I mean for me it's
my family all my family's online you
know my mom is on Twitter my sister's on
Twitter my father uses skype he doesn't
even know he's using instant messenger
you know but he he'll type would be like
you home and then he'll call me on the
telephone but that sort of combination
of things plus the ubiquity that the
people in your life even if they're not
kind of always on plugged in have access
to the internet know where it is and so
I can visit people in other rural areas
and usually be able to connect from
their home and so a lot of times you
know I'll come to somebody's house like
I did last night and be like okay I have
to check my web for 20 minutes and just
go into my little office you know
invisible office and do my things on my
laptop check my messages on my cell
phone and it's really changed you know
it used to be you'd go home and you
check your messages at your home who
wrote on the whiteboard who called me on
my phone that lives on the desk and now
you know checking it is as easy as
looking at your screen whatever that is
and doing whatever you need to do and
then you put your screen away and then
you're doing your other stuff I think
it's really blurred the work work / life
boundary which for me is excellent I
know for a lot of other people that's
the beginning of the end you know but
you're always at work and I'm like but I
love my job of course I'm always at work
like I'm always at work but I'm always
living my life to my work is just
they're the same and so that's really
watching that slowly tumble into Vermont
where that was my reality in seattle
back in 96 97 98 has been gratifying
although there's a lot of gloomy do me
sort of people being like oh I don't
know what that's going to be like and
I'm sort of the positive but not
wide-eyed cheerleader for the fact that
I think that's actually a good thing and
it's helpful for me personally and
enables me to have a job and I live in a
town of 3,000 people to whom I can't
explain what I do at all you know I'm
going to
flip this over and then checks arrive in
my you know in my bank account and and
that's that's what I do for a living